Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen.
Sommerzeit, Reisezeit. Wo bist du denn jetzt eigentlich?
Logbuch-Setzpolitik Nummer 2 äh Quatsch vierhundert vierhunderteinunddreißig. So viele Folgen haben wir schon zusammen vom zweiten Juni zwanzig zweiundzwanzig.
Ich hab's am 1. Juni noch geschafft nach Sylt. Bevor die den Hindenburgdamm gesprengt haben. Mit der Bahn.
Du hältst jetzt die Stellung.
23 Stunden habe ich gebraucht.
Aha, okay und wie war.
Nur Regionalbahn fahren.
Wie waren so deine Mitfahrer so.
Alle total locker drauf. Ja, nee, super.
Wie lange bleibst du jetzt?
Mal gucken, wie lange die brauchen, um diesen Bahndamm wieder aufzubauen.
Hotel für 9 Euro gekriegt.
Nee. Ich äh das Silvesterland ist ja direkt am Flughafen. Da kann man abends mitm Schlafsack rein. Da gibt's auch noch so Getränkeautomaten und so.
Das ist ja äh finde ich ja ein sehr schönes Meme, ja, das sich jetzt ausgerechnet diese Insel,
sorgt, dass dass alle mit ihren 9 Euro Tickets dahin fahren.
Ist das eigentlich so? Äh ich meine, Sorgen, die sich wirklich, ich würde mir an deren Stelle nicht sorgen.
Na ja, es gab ja einen Aufruf. Ähm ich glaube, von der APPD oder was? Äh ich weiß nicht genau ja.
Aber noch lange nicht, dass die sich Sorgen machen. Ich meine, ihr dürften wahrscheinlich mit Hotelpreisen immer noch die Feierwahl hoch genug äh haben.
Bild DE ist ja bei mir geblockt, ne? Aber die Überschriften kommen ja trotzdem bei Google, ja? Sylt, 9 Euro Ticket bedeutet Stresstest für die Insel. Die ersten Punker sind schon da.
Sylt unter Druck. Die 9 Euro Leute kommen. 9 Euro nach Sylt. Wir haben's ausprobiert. Also ich ich habe ehrlich gesagt den Eindruck
Sylt in Sorge wegen 9 Euro Ticket, das verselbstständigt sich jetzt.
Äh das wird jetzt eine selbsterfüllende Prophezeiung. Die werden sich wünschen, äh sie hätten dann gebaut.
Mich erinnert das so ein bisschen wie den Ansturm der Arbeitslosen, den Christoph da mal äh angekündigt hat am was war das? Wörthersee, wo irgendwie Helmut Kohl seinen Urlaub macht.
Da waren sie ja auch alle schon in Angst und Bange, dass jetzt hier irgendwie der Arbeitslosenherer über den See schwimmen.
Natürlich auch nicht stattgefunden, da ist aber einfach die Ankündigung ist sozusagen schon die eigentliche Botschaft.
Auf Telegram und Facebook gründen sich Gruppen, die zu den Chaostagen 2022 auf Sylt aufrufen. Hey Leute, lasst uns zusammen mit Dosenbier und Hunden nach Sylt fahren und die Yuppies ärgern.
Also das äh das ist jetzt so.
Ich weiß nicht mal ehrlich warst du schon mal auf Sylt, in deinem Leben jemals?
Äh also nicht, dass ich mich erinnern kann, aber ich war an an relativ vielen Orten schon mal und Sylt kann dazugehören.
Hm. Okay. Also hin wollen in dem Sinne, also so ein Gefühl hast du jetzt aber nicht in dir. Abgesehen davon, dass du schon da bist.
Ja also es ist äh so eine Arschloch-Insel, ne.
Also ich klar, wenn wenn man da jetzt genug wenn man mit genug vernünftigen Leuten dahin fährt, um die anderen zu ärgern, dann und das nur 9 Euro kostet, dann kann ich jetzt nicht sagen, gescheitert am Geld.
Aber insgesamt glaube ich nicht, dass das ein Ort ist, an dem es mich jetzt zieht.
Ihr wollt nach Ninas Sylt.
Ich weiß, da gibt's so ein Fischrestaurant, das soll ganz gut sein. Aber wir sagen jetzt nicht welches?
Das gibt's auch überall sonst auch.
Genau, das gibt's überall sonst auch. Das äh da ist auch eins hier am Marlene Dietrich-Platz. Ansonsten sieht das auch relativ klein aus da, ne? Das ist, glaube ich, gar nicht so eine große Insel.
Das Problem löst sich ja sowieso von alleine, weil das Ding ist ja irgendwie bald weggeweht. Weggeschwimmt.
Ja
Ich finde, man muss sich auch nicht so viel Gedanken über Sylt machen, um ehrlich zu sein.
Nein, das kriegen wir. Das ist erledigt. Die Insel ist durch. 20 23 will da keiner mehr hin.
Ja, lass sie, ihr Eis lecken.
Also die hängt da ja eh schon dran wie so ein Blinddarm das Ding ist durch. Also da könnt ihr euch was Neues suchen. Amrum soll ganz nett sein.
Wir haben auf jeden Fall andere Veranstaltungstipps für euch, die äh sind besser.
Ja. Warum nicht mal warum nicht mal neue Bundesländer Tim?
Sind die eigentlich noch so neu?
Heißen doch noch so oder?
Neulich bin ich mal durch eins durchgefahren. Das sah schon wieder ein bisschen abgewetzt aus. Aber na ja.
Die sehen insgesamt schon noch ganz gut aus.
Ja, stimmt. Hängt immer ein bisschen davon ab, wo man genau ist.
Wir werden in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern ähm eine Livesendung machen auf dem Fusion Festival. Das ist cool, ne? Da wurden wir äh eingeladen, eine Logbuchnetzpolitik zu machen.
Immer mal auflegen.
Ja, ich ich wollte auch schon immer mal auflegen,
Aber leider ähm als als mein Agent anrief Linus die Fusion und ich dachte, er liegt der Durchbruch als DJ. Und dann so, ja, Logbuch na, gut.
Meinetwegen.
Endlich der durch. Ähm aber ja guck mal, ich könnte auch mal wieder ein neues äh Dschungelmusikset verlinken. Ja, mache ich einfach mal. Habe ich nämlich gestern hochgeladen.
Okay, auf jeden Fall,
Fusion Festival. Nein, ihr kriegt jetzt da keine Tickets mehr. Braucht ihr gar nichts zu probieren, aber wenn ihr sowieso da seid, dann kommt doch einfach rum im Content und wir haben auch so einen Slot von um den es glaube ich keiner beneidet, ne?
Also da war auf jeden Fall Prime Time.
Primetime heißt auf so einem Festival man ist schon irgendwie komplett durch. Was heißt Samstag?
Samstagabend einundzwanzig Uhr.
Abend einundzwanzig Uhr, alle die das die Veranstaltung kennen, kichern jetzt schon ein bisschen. Und das ist dann genau welches Datum das ist dann der.
Zweite Juli.
Zweiter Juli, okay.
Ja. Also ich denke, das ist in Ordnung, also außer für Tim und mich, die er dann da fit sein müssen.
Ähm aber wir haben auch eine Möglichkeit gefunden, äh da die Last von uns zu nehmen. Wir haben uns einfach natürlich zwei hochkarätige Gäste eingeladen. Die Kündigung war aber jetzt mal noch nicht an, oder? Wer weiß, ob die noch absagen?
Ja genau, man weiß es ja nicht.
Beide noch nicht bei Logbuchnetzpolitik äh zu Gast gewesen.
Doch die eine, eine der beiden ist schon mal bei Logbuch-Netz-Boutique vor sehr langer Zeit zu Gast gewesen.
Der, die das andere Gästin, um jetzt nicht zu viel zu verraten, noch nicht.
Und wir haben ja ungefähr neunzig Minuten, die wir dort füllen. Also so ein halbes Stündchen, dreiviertel Stündchen mit beiden,
in angenehmer Atmosphäre, das heißt gegen 2230 könnt ihr dann
losziehen in Richtung Turmbühne und ich denke, das ist ein ganz gutes äh das ist ein ganz guter Samstag, der dann da sich ergeben.
Na klar. Aber alle anderen, ihr habt äh also ihr braucht keine Angst zu haben, die Veranstaltung wird natürlich aufgezeichnet und dann veröffentlicht, wie's immer der Fall ist.
Außer für die, die wirklich bei der Fusion sind, für die wird die nicht aufgezeichnet und veröffentlicht, für alle anderen schon.
Da müsst ihr schon kommen. Äh ja damit sind wir genau zweiter Juli Sandwiche noch mal ankündigen ist ja in einem in einem Monat ist das schon Tim.
So sieht's aus. Gut, kommen wir zum äh Feedback. Hm hatten wir.
Fehler gemacht.
Nicht so viel, aber wir haben einen kleinen äh Fehler durchgehen lassen, denn es wurde äh behauptet im Rahmen der Diskussion um die Chat-Kontrolle.
Die ähm Kinderschutzregelung, die jetzt von der Kommission auf den Weg gebracht wird, dass sich dabei um eine,
Richtlinie handelt und da schrieb uns dann gleich Holger, Holger Bleich, schöne Grüße. Moin ihr beiden, habe gerade auf dem Rad auf dem Weg,
Arbeit NMP gehört, da ich selbst gerade zur Chatkontrolle schreibe, war ich irritiert bis entsetzt, dass ihr meintet, es handle sich um eine Richtlinie. Ich dachte, ich hätte alles falsch berichtet,
Nein, es ist tatsächlich ein Verordnungsvorschlag Sie hier die äh siehe hier die PM der Kommission, in der auch der Volltext verlinkt ist, Link findet ihr bei uns in den Shownotes. Ja,
Holger äh ist ja Profi, schreibt bei Heise äh zu diesen Themen, hatten ihn ja hier auch schon mal in der Sendung und ähm natürlich hat er Recht, weil er ist ja ein richtiger Journalist und nicht so dahergelaufen,
Vögel, wie wir und überprüft ja seine Aussagen, ne. Und wir lassen uns einfach nur korrigieren.
Unterschied zwischen Verordnung und Richtlinie nochmal erklären, Tim?
Ja, also eine Richtlinie auf EU-Ebene ist so eine Ansage wie hör mal, wir haben uns das mal überlegt,
Im Wesentlichen sollte dieser Politikbereich in etwa so geregelt sein,
sitzt das dann doch mal bitte um in den nächsten Jahren, damit euer Gesetzestext so in etwa so klingt, wie wir uns das gedacht haben. Aber jedes Land kann das quasi selbst nach eigenen,
Bedürfnissen und Vorstellungen quasi umsetzen und wenn's dann halt nicht passt, dann muss man klagen und dann geht's hin und her et cetera. Das ist, sagen wir mal, die etwas,
lockerer,
Anweisungen aus Europa, die Richtlinie, man gibt quasi eine Richtlinie vor, dann muss man die Gesetzgebung entsprechend gestalten. Eine Verordnung, wie zum Beispiel die Datenschutzgrundverordnung, das ist
mehr oder weniger das Äquivalent zu einem richtigen europäischen Gesetz, weil das, was da drin steht, das gilt genau so, unmittelbar
sofort in allen Ländern und überall gleich. Heißt nicht, dass es da noch in allen Ländern
gleich zur Anwendung kommt, anderes Problem, grade Datenschutzgrundverordnung hatten wir ja schon tausendmal diese Beispiele. Ist ein anderes Problem, aber dass es quasi immer der ähm der größere Hammer, ne, also eine eine Grundverordnung ist,
Immer das starke äh Reglement die Richtlinie ist eher das kann man doch mal drüber reden.
Vor allem, wo dann so Details übrig bleiben. Jetzt will ich nicht schon den nächsten Fehler machen, aber ich glaube, Vorortsdatensprechung war eine Richtlinie.
Der kann dann, ne, in so einer Richtlinie steht drin, mindestens, also ich stelle mir jetzt irgendein Beispiel mindestens drei Monate,
höchstens sechs
oder äh folgende Daten sollen mindestens erfasst werden oder oder oder und dann haben die einzelnen Länder Möglichkeiten zu sagen, hör mal, machen wir aber bei uns mal ein bisschen anders oder so, aber die Richtige kann eben untererfüllt werden oder,
theoretisch jetzt grundsätzlich auch,
übererfüllt werden. Das wären dann Verstöße gegen die Bestrebung der Homogenisierung, ne, während die Verordnung eben klar ist, so wie das ist jetzt ein EU-Gesetz und das wird überall gleich umgesetzt. Das wollte man natürlich bei der.
Äh Datenschutzgrundverordnung verhindern, dass so etwas passieren würde. Ähm also zu viel,
Unterschiedlichkeiten, weil man ja schon die Erfahrung hatte, was passiert, wenn äh,
starten, wenn Unternehmen das als Standortvorteil von Staaten anerkennen und insofern macht es schon Sinn an dieser Stelle,
eine Verordnung zu machen, das macht's aber natürlich umso schlimmer, äh was jetzt dieses ähm Vorgehen oder dieses dieses diese Absicht.
Betrifft.
Genau. Also grundsätzlich ist es sind Verordnungen zu begrüßen dahingehend als dass dann eben eine höhere Rechtssicherheit besteht, aber wenn natürlich das, was da drinsteht, totaler Bullshit ist nicht so geil.
Genau und das ist hier der Fall. Wir können ja mal ganz kurz zusammenfassen, was im Bereich
der ähm dieses Themenbereich Chatkontrolle so noch passiert ist seit unserer letzten Sendung. Ähm,
Justizminister hat sich
skeptisch geäußert. Ich glaube, das hatten wir sogar noch erwähnt. Wichtig war ja, diese oder groß war die Sorge, was macht Nancy Faser? Die hat sich ziemlich klar positioniert, was den Spiegel,
sogar zu der äh Überschrift,
brachte Messengerüberwachung dürfte an Deutschland scheitern. Bundesinnenministerin Feser hat ihre Meinung zum Vorgaben zum Vorhaben der EU-Kommission geändert,
Das stimmt, sie hatte ursprünglich etwas anderes zu äh dazu gesagt. Jede private Nachricht anlasslos zu kontrollieren,
halte ich nicht für vereinbar mit unseren Freiheitsrechten. Die Falle ist natürlich, was meint also, ne, was macht.
Was macht meinst du mit Anlass bezogen? Also eine Möglichkeit für Nancy Phaser jetzt äh so eine SPD,
den doppelten äh SPD Rittberger
zu liefern, wäre zu sagen, ja aber Anlass bezogen wäre schon in Ordnung. Insofern bauen wir die Funktionalität überall ein und und der Anlass kommt dann äh den können wir ja dann immer noch definieren, von mir aus auch technisch oder sonst was, ja?
Ähm also hier ist weiter sehr vorsichtig,
draufzuschauen, da haben Justizminister Buschmann und der Minister für ist es jetzt digitales und Verkehr oder Verkehr und Digitales? Nee, Digital ist ein Verkehr, ne? Äh Volker Wissing haben sich da relativ klar,
unmissverständlich haben. Von distanziert von diesen Ideen. Gleichzeitig schreibt Erich Möchel,
bei FM vier, dass dieses EU-weite Überwachungsnetz schon in der Aufbauphase ist. Ja, es gibt also schon einen Fonds,
Der von der Kommission dafür bereitgestellt wird, ein Pilotprojekt äh äh auszurollen.
Und Softwaretools für Data Main Mining sollen äh bezahlt werden. KI-Forschungsprojekte äh entwickelt werden. Ja also hier sind schon Investitionen
Ausschreibungen ähm,
klar um diese Sache einzurichten, um das zu bauen ähm obwohl es noch gar nicht beschlossen ist. Also ich hatte das auch in einem Interview mit dem Bericht aus Berlin zu beziehungsweise ein,
Tagesschau Social oder so was. Der Tagesschau Social ist das glaube ich oder Tagesthemen Social. Gesagt insgesamt.
Wird dieses Vorhaben zu lange vorbereitet,
Ja? Wir erinnern uns ähm die Diskussion vor zwei, drei Jahren. Dann die konkrete Abschwächung der e-Privacy-Richtlinie, wo wir Schutzrechte erstmal abgebaut bekommen. Jetzt ein Jahr später ziemlich genau, ein Jahr später, diese,
Grundrechtsverletzung oder diese Schutzrechtsverletzung nun zur,
zum Gesetz wird, ja, die die vor einem Jahr noch verboten war, wird jetzt zum soll jetzt per Regelfall zum Gesetz werden. Das alles ist seit so langer Zeit geplant, da sind so starke Interessen hinter, dass sich es sehr, sehr, für sehr, sehr unwahrscheinlich halte.
Dass nun äh Nancy Phaser,
Volker Wissing und Buschmann, Entschuldigung jetzt weiß ich den Vornamen noch nicht, mit dem bin ich noch nicht so äh mit Marco,
ne? Äh Marco Buschmann, dass die drei jetzt die Europäische Union davor retten werden. Das wird nicht reichen,
Ähm also da dürfen wir uns nicht zurücklehnen. Da müssen wir weiter in den internationalen Protest. Da müssen wir vor allem auch in Deutschland den Protest aufrechterhalten, weil das wird also
Das reicht noch nicht, ja? Insofern äh glaube ich ähm.
Also es würde reichen, wenn wenn das dazu führt, dass die Bundesregierung generell ihre Haltung ändert.
Richtig und na ja vor allem dann ist ja noch der Punkt äh,
das ist auch das Fazit dieses Artikels, dass Deutschland den Entwurf zumindest in dieser Form im Rat nicht zustimmen wird. Ja aber,
Mhm also da werden sie schon noch einen Weg finden und meine persönliche Vermutung wäre, dass das werden sie jetzt irgendwie bei Nancy Phasers Definition von Anlass oder Anlasslosigkeit,
machen. Gleichzeitig habe ich in der letzten Sendung gelacht über äh Chatgruppen mit der Polizei, ja? Die einzigen Kriminellen Chatgruppen scheinen irgendwie vom Polizisten betrieben zu werden. Ähm ne also und und
äh Drogenhändler ähm natürlich, aber das ist äh das interessiert ja keinen. Ähm.
Da gibt's also jetzt hier der die Hessenschau berichtet, dass der Innenausschuss des Landtags Hessen ja ähm,
Da wurde also mal gesagt, soll jetzt mal Bericht erstattet werden. Ähm weil äh vier,
und eine Beamte in der hessischen Polizei wegen rechter Chatgruppen angeklagt sind und ähm insgesamt soll es aber 67 rechte Chatgruppen bei der hessischen Polizei gegeben haben, zum Teil auch mit,
Kinderpornographischen Inhalten.
Von 67 Chatgruppen hat man Kenntnis erhalten.
Genau, ja.
Es könnte auch noch mehr gegeben haben. Es sei denn, sie haben alle gefunden.
Durch Zufall entdeckt im Rahmen der Ermittlung zur NSU zwei Punkt null Affäre.
Katastrophe, ja? 35 von diesen 67 rechten Chatgruppen haben Anlass für strafrechtliche Ermittlungen gegeben.
Und 110 Polizeikräfte haben sich in diesem Kontext strafrechtlich verhalten,
während es unklar ist, wie viele weitere tatenlos zugeschaut haben. Also ne, kannst dir überlegen, 11 Polizeikräfte verteilt auf ähm fünfunddreißig Chatgruppen.
Schon mal fast also drei bis 4 pro Gruppe. Jetzt gucken wir mal, wie groß die Gruppe ist. Also drei bis vier Polizistinnen, die strafrechtlich relevante Inhalte,
in diesem Gruppen gepostet haben, wurden von den anderen ähm toleriert.
Ne, also da kann man sagen, eine Krähe hackt der anderen kein Auge aus, ist hier noch relativ schlecht, ne, also keine Krähe hackt den anderen Dreier im Auge aus. Also das ist das ist natürlich ähm völlig äh völlig inakzeptabel.
Aber Linus das muss doch eine Falschmeldung sein. Wie sollen sie denn das ohne Chatkontrolle überhaupt rausgefunden haben? Die haben doch überhaupt nicht die Werkzeuge dafür.
Das äh ist genau die Frage, ne?
Aber es ist insofern eine interessante Meldung, als das dann ja vielleicht vor allem die Polizei Angst haben müsste vor der Polizei. Hat eigentlich die Polizei Angst vor der Polizei?
Ich glaube, die äh die die Polizei hat nur Angst vorm Datenschutz.
Also ganz offensichtlich muss die Polizei ja keine Angst vor der Polizei haben, wenn sie Straftaten vor den Augen der Polizei begehen kann. Da sind nicht die einzige äh Straftat, glaube ich, die Polizistinnen vor den Augen anderer Polizistinnen äh begehen. Ähm,
Es gab jetzt auch wieder einen Erfolg der Polizei in der Aufklärung von,
Banden, die sich mit Dokumentationen von Kindesmissbrauch verdingen, nämlich der Missbrauchskomplex Kirchen.
Wo äh insgesamt gegen 74 Tatverdächtige ermittelt wird. Ähm Nordrhein-Westfalen, 44 Jahre alter Mann aus Wermelskirchen, der ähm,
Also Taten verübt haben, gefilmt und fotografiert haben soll,
32 Terabyte Daten wurden äh bei der Festnahme dieses Mannes sichergestellt, Millionen Bild- und Videodateien.
Und was natürlich offen leider oder offensichtlich hier wieder fehlt, ist,
in irgendeiner Chatgruppe gewesen wäre, wo er diese 32 Terrabyte getauscht hätte, ja. Das äh ist ja also ist ja auch wir haben das ja in vergangenen Sendungen immer wieder gesagt, das ist nicht das, wie diese Täter operieren,
Chatkontrolle ist nicht der Weg, äh der diesen Tätern ähm Kopfschmerzen machen wird. Nichtsdestotrotz,
äh wird natürlich auch äh von dem ähm NRW-Innenminister jetzt in dieses Horn geblasen, der dann nämlich bekannt gibt, das Problem wäre ja nun mal der Datenschutz,
Ähm der in äh zum ähm Verzweifeln bringe, er wolle zwar, dass der gewahrt bleibe, aber äh,
Täter sich schwer in der Frage. Weil Daten da wird ja dann auch wieder so ein bisschen komisch ähm.
Daten dürften nicht dauerhaft gespeichert werden und deswegen stießen Behörden an die Grenzen.
Und ich weiß nicht genau, was Sie welche Daten er meint? Wahrscheinlich meint er,
ähm ein Vorratsdaten und möchte so ein bisschen in diese Richtung gehen, aber der der Hintergrund ist ja eigentlich, wenn man sich überlegt, wie solche Diskussionen geführt werden, die werden ja emotional geführt und auch emotional entschieden,
und oder hoffe also deren Plan ist das emotional zu entscheiden. Das heißt sie brauchen auch nicht wirklich sage ich mal
Argumente zu bringen, die sinnvoll sind. Ja, so kommen ja solche Ideen wie Chatkontrolle in die Welt, dass jeder, der sich ein bisschen mit dem
Mit der Technik und dem Themenkomplex auskennt, sofort erkennt, dass es Unsinn, aber wir sind halt auch nicht Adressaten der Botschaft.
Und wenn man dann sagt, hier, schon wieder äh Missbrauchskomplex, ich verzweifle am Datenschutz, das reicht,
für viele Menschen, wenn sie sehen, oh mein Gott, der Innenminister verzweifelt am Datenschutz und wir müssen die Kinder schützen. Ähm das das funktioniert eben, ne?
Leider, aber der Begriff Datenschutz ist halt auch wirklich äh immer wieder sehr missverständlich gewählt so, ne. Es sind ja nicht die Daten, die geschützt werden, ne.
Datenschutz ist wirklich ein
ein sehr äh ein sehr uneinheitlich verwendeter Begriff, der leider zu sehr also immer wieder zu großen äh also ein ein ein so unklar definierter Begriff, dass er sehr gut zum Prügelknaben,
sich eignet, ja? Wir erinnern uns an Diskussionen zur Corona-Warn-App und was nicht alles, ja, ähm,
Katastrophe, ja? Dann äh.
Erinnern wir uns daran, dass wir im letzten Jahr das auch das zitiert äh in der letzten Sendung.
Dass das BKA keine Löschung äh von gefundenen Materialien ähm veranlasst hat, ja,
und äh,
Jetzt gibt's eine gab's eine Anfrage schon im März von äh Anke Domscheid Berg, äh die gefragt hat, was soll das denn eigentlich, warum passiert das denn eigentlich nicht? Und im Prinzip gibt's
quasi gar nicht äh also sagt die Bundesregierung, die BKA das BKA ist überhaupt nicht dafür zuständig äh,
Löschung überhaupt zu veranlassen,
was richtig geil ist, ja? Also wenn du wenn die sagen, nee, nee, löschen brauchen die nicht, kann ich nicht Aufgabe der Polizei sein, jetzt hier diese Materialien verschwinden zu lassen. Wir brauchen eine Chatkontrolle.
Also das ist das zeigt ja wirklich nur, wie völlig äh,
völlig unsinnig. Die diese Gesamtargumentationslinie ist und leider, ne, wird's ist kann ich mich nur wiederholen, wenn da jetzt nicht ein riesengroßer Protest stattfindet.
Und der sich auch innerhalb der Europäischen Union internationalisiert,
ist das Ding äh nicht mehr zu halten, nicht mehr zu stoppen.
Ganz im Gegensatz zum Verifon-Modell H fünftausend.
Das funktioniert nicht so gut, oder?
Und zwar ist das H fünftausend ein ähm Point of Sales Terminal vom Hersteller,
Und ein Terminal ist das, wo ihr eure äh Kreditkarte reinsteckt oder kontaktlos dranhaltet und
ähm vielleicht noch eure PIN eingebt und im Supermarkt bezahlt, zum Beispiel bei Aldi Nord Aldi Süd, Lidl, Rewe, Penny, Edeka Rossmann, toom,
und vielen Tankstellen, eine relativ weit verbreitetes äh Zahlungsterminal.
Nicht nur dort auch in meinem Fahrradladen zum Beispiel kam glaube ich so ein Terminal zum Einsatz. Auf jeden Fall war da auch einige Tage lang äh immer der Hinweis mit ja äh sorgt dafür, dass ihr Bargeld dabei habt, um das Fahrrad abzuholen.
Ja, das äh.
Es ist das meistverkaufte Terminal Deutschlands und es ist schon etwas älter und,
Was hier ähm es wird zum Neuverkauf nicht mehr angeboten. Es gibt äh Nachfolgemodelle und was jetzt passiert ist, ist.
Dass ein Rut-Zertifikat oder oder ein entscheidendes Zertifikat in diesem Gerät ist,
abgelaufen. Das letzte Update mit einem neuen Zertifikat kam im Dezember 21 und,
Das würde aber wohl nicht auf allen installiert und diejenigen, die dieses Update nicht haben, bei denen hat jetzt Ende Mai, Anfang Juni, offenbar muss das ja gewesen sein, Ende Mai. Äh,
ist das Zertifikat abgelaufen und jetzt funktionieren die Geräte nicht mehr.
Das ist lustig, weil die also weil die jetzt irgendeine Form von ähm manuellem Update äh brauchen würde ich mal erwarten.
Du kannst es also nur noch ähm irgendwie,
manuell updaten, weil üblicherweise, so wie sich das jetzt anhört, wenn dieses Zertifikat wird der Vertrauensanker auch sein für das Herunterladen ähm von,
Updates und wenn du eben dieses Zertifikat weg ist oder nicht mehr gültig ist, vertraut das Gerät dem auch nicht mehr. Ja? Und da das äh,
könnte es jetzt noch versuchen es äh dem Gerät weiß zu machen, dass es eine Woche früher ist,
könnte es nochmal funktionieren, aber ähm das wird auch nicht äh so ohne Weiteres möglich sein, denn je nachdem, was du da für ein Gerät hast, hat das potenziell auch einfach einen ähm.
GSM Zugang. Ja also das ist äh,
Ein Klassiker gewissermaßen, der immer dann äh vorkommt, wenn man mit Zertifikaten arbeitet, weshalb viele Unternehmen auch ähm geneigt sind, ihre Zertifikate extra lang gültig zu machen,
Damit auch wirklich,
Jede Mitarbeiterin und jeder Mitarbeiter, der noch weiß, wann das Zertifikat abläuft, bis dahin das Unternehmen verlassen hat,
und dann hast du genau äh diese schöne Situation. Wenn mal interessiert, wie dir die Sache jetzt diskutieren werden, weil ähm,
da sie ein Update bereitgestellt haben ähm bin ich mal, also frage ich mich mal, wer jetzt da am Ende dann dafür verantwortlich ist.
Also wer sozusagen die Haftung äh zu übernehmen hat. Also ich meine, Sie haben ja ein Softwareup,
angeboten, einspielen wie schon erwähnt, muss man das dann irgendwie manuell, da weiß ich jetzt auch nicht, wie das geregelt ist, wer das tut, ob das sozusagen die Kunden selber machen oder ob man dann einen Support-Termin ähm,
vereinbaren muss.
Äh insgesamt seien ja noch das Versprechen im Raum bis Ende 23 Softwareupdates für dieses Gerät zu liefern. Danach ist es dann sowieso äh vorbei damit.
Ähm das weiß ich jetzt nicht. Also was da äh die Modalitäten sind. Aber zeigt natürlich auf der einen Seite,
ist ein Problem, also weil so ein Gerät ist natürlich äh als Point of Sale und sozusagen als als Kontakt mit
meiner persönlichen Security-Architektur äh ein wichtiges Device, selbstverständlich braucht das Softwareupdate, selbstverständlich ist es auch korrekt, dass wenn da ein Zertifikat,
Abgelaufen ist, dass er's dann auch nicht mehr akzeptiert wird. Ne, also insofern verhält sich da ja alles richtig, nur dass man,
ähm eben auch dafür sorgen muss, dass es Updates hat und das weiß jetzt nicht ganz genau von wann dieses also seit wann dieses Gerät im Verkauf,
überhaupt ist. Also es wurde noch bis 2019 verkauft. Aber ich weiß jetzt nicht genau,
wie alt es ist, gilt allerdings hier in dem einen Artikel, ist von äh,
Seit 20018 auf dem Abstellgleis, also was immer jetzt das genau,
bedeutet aber scheint auf jeden Fall schon etwas länger unterwegs zu sein das Teil.
Also äh wir hatten mal vor vielen Jahren in in meinem
Team damals äh Payment Terminals gehackt, da waren noch andere verbreiteter. Dieses hat aber, glaube ich, auch, wenn ich das richtig sehe, schon NFC also würde ich mal schätzen, dass das vielleicht so von,
18 oder so etwa von 2013 oder so angefangen wurde.
Äh dreizehn, 20, 13 von der Firma Verifon. Mhm, genau. Wurde aber offiziell bereits Ende 18 aus dem Verkauf genommen.
Und äh entspricht seit Anfang des Jahres 2022 nicht mehr den technischen Vorschriften.
Bereits installierte Geräte durften nur noch aufgrund einer großzügig bemessenen Übergangsfrist der deutschen Kreditwirtschaft bis 2025 betrieben werden,
Aha. Also die deutsche Kreditwirtschaft hat gesagt, ja mmm meinetwegen, dann benutzt es doch noch ein bisschen, aber hat wohl nicht ausreichend darauf hingewiesen, dass man dann entsprechende Softwareupdates für liefern muss. Na ja.
Also üblicherweise, das kaufst du dir ja auch nicht wirklich, das kaufst du als Endverbraucherin nicht direkt bei Vodafone, sondern das kriegst du von deinem Zahlungsdienstleister.
Nicht Vodafone.
Sorry bei Verifon, äh der kauft das Veriv also der Zahlungsdienstleister. Hier werden zum Beispiel zitiert Payone und Concardis, die kaufen die Dinger halt, ne, in großen Mengen bei Verifon,
provisionieren die dann für dich und sagen alles klar hier ist deins, ja? Und dann swipst du da äh Karten und was nicht alles und am Ende macht dieser Zahlungsdienstleister eine Abrechnung mit dir. Du zahlst eine Gerätemiete oder Gerätepauschale, äh du zahlst eine ähm
Umsatz ab eine Umsatzbeteiligung, ne und dann hast du äh Kartenzahlung.
Und die sagen die sind aber natürlich jetzt dafür verantwortlich dir dieses Gerät.
Was sie nicht mit einem Update versehen haben, wie der funktionsfähig zu machen und für die ist jetzt die Situation als Kleid, dann fahr mal raus zum Kunden,
mach irgendeinen manuellen Boot, in irgendeinen Firmware-Update-Modus und hoffe, dass du da nochmal ein Firmwareupdate reinkriegst, damit das Ding dann nochmal bis 2023 benutzt werden kann, die raten natürlich dazu
den lieber die neuen Geräte zu nehmen weil der,
Gerätetausch potentiell schneller geht, als wenn ihre Techniker da jetzt rausfahren. Also am Ende hat,
sogar noch was davon. Aber es ist lustig, also jetzt auch kein so großes Problem. Ich würde sagen ähm wenn das jetzt durch Hacker verursacht wäre, dann wäre ein Riesenthema.
Aber ähm den Cyber War gewinnen immer noch die Doofen und in dem Fall sind die eben einfach bei den bei den Betreibern.
So, dann haben wir eine ein neues,
Also ich wurde da schon vor einigen Wochen oder gar Monaten immer mal wieder drauf hingewiesen. Ähm,
Vodafone und Deutsche Telekom haben sich offenbar ein Geschäftsmodell,
ausgedacht und dieses Geschäftsmodell ähm ist mir auf technischer Ebene immer noch nicht hundertprozentig klar, was sie da vorhaben. Die Informationen, die sie dazu geben.
Sind aber äh also sind für mich,
nicht vollständig ausreichen, um technisch zu verstehen, wie das funktionieren soll. Insofern werden wir ein bisschen äh spekulieren müssen, aber die Situation ist,
Erstmal folgende, also Ausgangssituation, alles äh hier in Logbuch Netzpolitik berichtet und ich fasse das mal wie folgt zusammen. Wir kennen.
Die unterschiedlichen Bestrebungen.
Ähm Werbung im Internet von ihrer Tracking-Fähigkeit,
zu befreien, sie also zu beschneiden. Wir haben insgesamt nur relativ wenige Werbeplattformen, die,
ähm im Internet weit verbreitet sind, ja, die was weiß ich, bei,
Spiegel Online gleichermaßen wie bei eurer äh Lieblingsseite zum Thema äh Neun-Euro-Ticket oder sonst was immer eingebunden werden und dadurch in der Lage sind, euch,
über das Internet zu verfolgen und zu und somit ein Profil über euch zu bilden und zu erkennen.
Was denn eure Interessen sind, ja? Das sind das machen sie über sogenannte Third Party Cookies, also sie
bilden sie ähm in der Webseite, die ihr besucht, ist ein kleiner
ein kleiner ein kleines Fenster drin der sagt hier lädst du bitte den Inhalt von diesen Werbenetzwerk das Werbenetzwerk hat dir ein Cookie gegeben, er kennt dich an dem Cookie wieder und weiß ach super, das ist der Tim der hat gerade bei Spiegel Online das und das gelesen und jetzt siehst du bei heiße dieses und jenes
ne? In beiden Fällen kommt die Werbung
Von dem Werbenetzwerk, das nun ähm sage ich mal sich Bilder von deinen oder ein Profil von deinen Interessen bildet und,
ähm natürlich ein Interesse hat, dieses Bild nicht,
zu verlieren, ja? Oder zum Beispiel äh sicherzustellen, dass wenn du morgen äh das Internet aufmachst, dass ihr Cookie noch da ist.
Wichtig dabei zu verstehen ist, es handelt sich hier nicht um das Trecking, wie man das jetzt sozusagen innerhalb einer Webseite hat, ne, das was so diese Cookie-Bänder bei den Webseiten, die man so ansurft äh repräsentieren, sondern hier geht's eben wirklich auch über das
firmenübergreifende Tracking, ne? Dass man also wirklich über alle Internetaktivitäten äh hinweg ist, sodass wenn man eben bei Amazon noch irgendwas gesucht hat,
zu irgendeinem anderen Shop,
will quasi diese Webseite im Idealfall bereits wissen, wonach du gesucht hast und dir die Werbung dafür schon äh mit dem ersten Aufruf der Webseite vor die Nase knallen und nicht noch drauf warten, dass du da auch noch mal denselben Suchstrick eingibst.
Genau und das also der der Effekt ist ja wirklich spannend, wenn man sich mal so einen jungfräulichen Browser einrichtet und einfach alle Cookies löscht.
Und dann äh auch äh also alle AdBlocker deaktiviert, äh was dann wenn man dann irgendwann einmal so in einem bestimmten,
Themenbereich gelandet ist
Und dann wird man ja wirklich nur noch damit zugeballert, ja. Also ich habe äh das äh so einen Instagram-Account äh Jamal gemacht und da klickst du einmal auf irgendeine Küchenwerbung oder auf oder folgst irgendwas.
Küchengeräten. Ich kriege jetzt alles nur noch Küche, ja, äh weil ich dieses Profil einfach noch nicht ausreichend geschärft habe für mich.
Das Interessante ist aber dann, dadurch, dass ich da überall Küchenwerbung kriege, weiß ich, dass die überall sonst auch daher kommt. Und da kommt dann natürlich schon,
Ist es denn irre, auf wie vielen Seiten du auf einmal Küchenwerbung bekommst, ja? Das ist ja auch das, was Menschen seit jeher ähm.
Am Internet ein bisschen gruselig finden. So, nun, dem wird entgegengetreten aus verschiedenen äh
ähm durchaus sinnvollen Richtungen, die wir diese werden immer weiter eingeschränkt. Apple hat das ja sogar schon in ihren Browser eingebaut, dass sie sagen, alles klar, wir wissen einfach, wer Trecker sind und wenn die uns Cookies geben, dann werfen wir die einfach weg
oder wir wir lassen uns jedes Mal Neuen geben und wir verhageln denen quasi diese Profilbildung.
Und das hat die richtig geschmerzt, das hat man ja an die Reaktionen und auch im Gewinneinbruch von Facebook gesehen.
Deshalb genau, Facebook also Apple hat,
weiterhin das auch in seinen Apps stark eingeschränkt, ne? Also das Tracking
über die Apps. Das iPhone liefert dir immer weniger Informationen anhand äh deren derer du überhaupt ein Profil bauen könntest.
Es gibt also nicht nur von Apple, sondern eher auch von rechtlicher Seite, von technischer Seite ähm einen sehr klaren Kampf
gegen diese Profilbildung. So. Das ist klar und dieser Kampf ist erfolgreich, deswegen jaulen die auch so laut. Ähm das ist erstmal,
eine positive Entwicklung. So, es gibt aber natürlich.
Wenn man jetzt einen solchen angestammten Tracking-Markt angreift, dann gibt es dann verlieren, was weiß ich, diejenigen, die den machen und es hat natürlich
Es gibt andere, die gewinnen, weil Werbung im Internet wird nicht sterben. Ja und das ähm,
natürlich dann potenziell so etwas wie Facebook und oder Google äh die den größeren Teil des Internets hosten
eventuell wieder zu den Gewinnern gehören, ist relativ naheliegend. Ähm außerdem.
Können die natürlich das Argument machen? Ich weiß nicht, ob es lauter ist, aber es wird herangefahren, dass sie sagen, na ja, die äh Verlage,
die verlieren ja jetzt Einnahmen und können verlieren somit ihre Unabhängigkeit. Also sie möchten,
gerne, dass die europäischen Datenschutzstandards gewahrt bleiben, aber sie möchten natürlich auch weiterhin uns ihre tollen Webseiten kostenlos anbieten und das geht in zunehmendem Maße nicht mehr. Ein sehr ähm,
Also ein Argument, dem ich ehrlich gesagt nicht folgen würde, weil ähm wir ja wissen.
Es funktioniert sehr wohl noch, äh weil wir ja den Trick kennen, dass diese hier mach mal unser Werbefreiabo, dass das Werbefreiabo eigentlich,
da ist, um die Leute
zu der Zustimmung zu zwingen, wieder diese Werbenetzwerke zuzulassen, nicht etwa um einen gleichen, gleich profitablen ähm,
Nutzer zu haben, der tatsächlich zahlt. Also äh nun ja, jedenfalls.
Damit mehr verdienen mit dem Geld und ich finde die Argumentation ist sogar noch ein funken perfide. Es ist ja äh nicht so, dass gesagt wird, ja aber die Verlage
Also nicht nur dieses weinerliche, aber die müssen doch auch von irgendwas leben. Nein, nein, es sind ja die User, die ja in den Benefit kommen, an einem kostenlosen Internet teilzunehmen, wo sie nichts,
zahlen müssen, das ist doch die eigentliche Freiheit.
Das wollten wir doch alle, ne?
Ist vielleicht auch ein bisschen was dran.
Ja, weil es gibt viele Leute, die nicht bereit sind für irgendwas zu bezahlen, für das Meiste. Ähm also kann man jetzt auch nicht ignorieren. Es gibt natürlich diese
Grundhaltung. Ob man das jetzt gleich so unter Freiheit äh abspeichern muss halte ich für diskutabel.
So jetzt kommt ähm und jetzt kommt 3. ins Spiel, nämlich die Netzwerkbetreiberinnen und Betreiber, die,
schon immer so ein bisschen sich darüber ärgern, dass dieses ganze Milliardengeschäft Internet abgeht ähm mit Netflix.
Mit Werbung und mit Bild Plus oder was wo überall viel Geld.
Anderen verdienen das Geld mit ihren Kunden, die ihnen ja gehören.
Mit ihrem Internet und ihren Kunden. Ja, das sind ja ihre, die bringen sie ja dahin.
Leibeigen.
Ja. So und jetzt kommen aber jetzt überlegen sie sich natürlich oder jetzt haben sich die Netzbetreiber überlegt hm sind wir nicht in einer Position.
Dass wir vielleicht die an diesem Geschäft ähm.
Teilhaben können.
Teilhaben könnten.
Kurz was einwerfen, ist noch gar nicht so lange her. Da war das mit diesem HTTPS,
Dieser Verschlüsselung von Webseiten und Zertifikaten und so weiter war alles noch Zukunft.
Mich noch sehr gut dran erinnern, wie irgendwie so auf Republikas und so weiter debattiert wurde, ob man nicht mal Facebook dazu zwingen könnte, man hatte DPS zu verwenden und so weiter. Also wir hatten wirklich ein komplett unverschlüsseltes Web
wo Passwörter durchging wie nix Gutes und die Mobilfunkbetreiber weltweit haben,
Nicht alle, aber sehr viele dann schon immer so Sachen gemacht, dass sie sich diese Webseiten, die ausgeliefert wurden, halt angeschaut haben im Traffic und tatsächlich die darin enthaltene Werbung
eigenständig geändert haben. Also sie sind da so richtig in das übertragene HTML reingegangen und haben gesagt so, ach ja, hier wird irgendwie von dem Werbepartner geworben, da,
Schreiben wir uns doch einfach mal rein. Also wir haben wirklich aktiv deine
deinen Datenfluss, den du mit irgendeiner anderen Webseite hast, äh quasi,
etwas hinein injiziert, damit sie dann quasi die Werbung ausliefern. Also auf dem Level war das schon damals und dann kam er,
HCTPS-Welle und dann so, oh ja wie was, das geht jetzt nicht mehr. Hm, was muss was anderes einfallen lassen?
Genau, die haben immer,
Du konntest auch früher, das weiß ich noch, hm einem meiner ersten Mobilfunkverträge gab's so ein Feature, da konnte ich sagen ey ähm ich will, dass ihr mir die Bilder kleiner rechnet
Das Internet ist ja groß, ne,
Ich möchte, dass ihr irgendeinen Proxy dazwischen schaltet, der die Bilder kleiner rechnet, damit ich mehr surfen kann und schneller surfen kann. Ja, also alles so oder oder auch äh ganz schlimm, also mit solchen Netzbetreibern arbeite ich ja gar nicht.
Äh äh rufst du irgendeine Seite auf, wirst sofort umgeleitet auf irgendeine Fuck-Such-Seite von denen.
Da kann ich auch also das da schneide ich sofort das Kabel durch. So und zwar an der an der Bordsteinkante, ne? Aber okay, was haben Sie sich jetzt überlegt?
Die haben sich überlegt, vielleicht können wir ja einen Gegenentwurf zu den Flirt Party Cookies machen und ähm.
Wir sind dann einfach die Provider dafür und was sie sich jetzt überlegt haben ist laut der Schilderung folgendes.
Sie generieren? Eine ID für dich?
Die wird gebaut aus deiner Telefonnummer und deiner IP-Adresse.
Das ist relativ einfach, weil du hast immer wieder eine andere IP-Adresse, ja, die wechselt sich, die die ändert sich regelmäßig, aber die wissen natürlich trotzdem auch zu jedem Zeitpunkt, welche du hast und die wissen auch
zu jedem Zeitpunkt, der eine Telefonnummer. Also bauen sie dir quasi einen sich automatisch änderndes Pseudonym,
Was sie sich merken und aus dem generieren sie,
Pseudonymen, Unique Token, den Trust Pit. Truston is ID heißt das wahrscheinlich oder sowas, ja? Und,
den Speichern nur Sie. Und wenn du jetzt eine äh Webseite von einem Advertiser besuchst, also in diesem Fall,
äh also irgendeine Werbung kriegst, ja, dann.
Bekommt der eine Website specific Token. Also, ich bin das Werbenetzwerk, der Tim.
Besucht Logwork Netzwerk DE, da gibt's kein Werbenetzwerk. Kommt auf äh besucht Spiegel Online DE, ja?
Spiegel DE und jetzt sagt das Ding hier ist der Websites, der sich aus deiner Trust PID und Spiegel DE ergibt.
Und das Netz, das sagt dann A okay, alles klar ähm wenn du sie können dich also deshalb jetzt nicht,
oder identifizieren, weil das eben Webseiten spezifisch ist.
Aber meine Interessen.
Wenn du zugestimmt hast, dann können diese.
Und die Publisher diesen Website spezifischen Token benutzen, um dir personalisierte Inhalte zu geben.
Gleichzeitig,
speichern die, also Vodafone Deutsche Telekom, eine Liste der Werber Werbeplattformen und Publisher, also Werbenetzwerke und Spiegel Online in unserem Fall, bei denen den, bei denen die du zugestimmt hast,
dass sie dir äh personalisierte Werbung oder ähm äh zuspielen dürfen oder auch Analysen ähm auf deinem Traffic machen dürfen,
und in deren Portal, also ihre zentrale Webseite, kannst du das jederzeit managen.
Was ich nicht ganz verstehe ist, wie kommt dieser Token überhaupt jemals in mein Gerät? Ja, weil,
Sie können und wenn ich die ganze Zeit nur hatte TPS spreche, können Sie nirgendwo in einem Traffic irgendetwas injekten. Also frage ich mich, woher wissen die?
Also wie können die dem Werbenetzweck mitteilen, dass ich ich bin? Oder äh downgraden sie an irgendeiner Stelle wieder auf HTTP, damit sie diesen äh äh Pseudonym misst Token da reinbauen können. Also so ganz ist mir das nicht klar.
Wie das technisch funktionieren soll, bin ich ganz ehrlich. Aber gehen wir mal davon aus, dass es äh in irgendeiner Weise funktioniert.
Dann hast du jetzt also ein Token, der mit deinem Netz,
Anschluss verbunden ist, der von deinem Netzanbieter verwaltet wird und den du nicht mehr los wirst. Den wirst du auch nicht los, wenn du dein Handy nimmst,
die SIM-Karte in ein anderes steckst, dann wandert der Token mit, weil der an deine Telefonnummer gebunden ist.
Weißt du, was das ist? Ist kein Netz Provider, ist ein Petzprovider, heißt das. Der der verpfeift dich einfach. Ich meine, du gehst dann irgendwie äh willst du einen Provider gibst ihm Geld so und dem verpetzt dich einfach.
Und jetzt sagen die aber nee, nee, das Tracking ermöglichen wir ja nicht. Was wir ja machen, ist ja Folgendes. Und zumindest die also man muss die Argumentation erfolgen können. Die sagen,
Pass mal auf. Vorher gehst du irgendwie aufs Internet, klickst einfach so ein Cookie-Banner weg.
Hast du eigentlich mal überlegt, wie du, wenn du da falsch geklickt hast, dass Cookie-Banner wiederbekommst um Nein zu sagen? Du müsstest ja
in äh deine Browser-Einstellung gehen und den spezifischen Cookie löschen. Du weißt aber gar nicht, welche von von deinen acht Millionen Cookies äh hier der richtige ist. Das heißt, dort kannst du ist es ja unglaublich schwierig, eine Übersicht über deine Zustimmung zu finden,
Ne, du kannst von mir aus, wenn jetzt einen Tag surfst und klickst ähm Konzentbaner an.
Da kann dir am kannst du am Ende anhand deiner Cookies nicht mehr feststellen was du überhaupt zugestimmt hast und was nicht. Wir bieten dir aber jetzt eine Webseite.
Zentral machen, da hast du ein ein äh Cockpit. Kannst du nämlich dann da, hast du dann,
und da kannst du dann schön sagen, ach ja hier äh die Webseite, die soll mich nicht mehr tracken, äh der habe ich das zwar mal erlaubt, aber das mache ich jetzt wieder weg. In da argumentieren sie also, da können sie ja eine eine Übersicht,
du normalerweise nicht hast, ist schon mal besser für dich.
Gleichzeitig argumentieren Sie aber diesem Argument kann ich auch nur bedingt folgen. Dass dich ja keiner mehr tracken kann, weil das ja anonym ist.
Du kannst es äh also du kannst es einschalten, ausschalten und,
Sie sagen im Prinzip so, wir stellen das aber auch nur bereit, wir monetarisieren nicht die Kundendaten und äh wir analysieren auch nicht den Datenverkehr.
Ähm aber dann ist die Frage, wer macht's denn dann, ja? Also sie sie sagen im Prinzip der Cookie,
Alle die die Mehrheit der Menschheit hat sich entschieden, den Cookie und den Sir Partikoki nicht mehr haben zu wollen. Also bauen wir den jetzt in unser Mobilfunknetz ein.
Für dich. Also es ist,
ich halte das nicht für eine sinnvolle Idee. Also ich halte es für erstens technisch nicht sauber umsetzbar, um ehrlich zu sein.
Und ich halte es also es kann nicht funktionieren ohne irgendwelche Abstriche entweder in in der Seitenladezeit oder in der verschlüsselten Übermittlung der Inhalte und ähm,
Ich denke, das ist hier relativ klar, dass Sie erkannt haben, alles klar. Wenn keiner mehr in der Lage, also wenn wirklich die Party Cookies
und die Browser tut den Browser nicht mehr da reintricksen kannst irgendwo eine ID zu haben, dann sind wir die einzigen, die die noch,
liefern können und zwar in richtig guter Qualität.
In richtig guter Qualität. Jemand hat zwei SIM-Karten, drei Geräte, alles klar, wir wissen immer noch, wer das ist. Und äh jemand hat, was weiß ich, Magenta Plus mit einem Heimanschluss und eine und einem Mobilfunkanschluss.
Kein Problem. Viel wissen immer, wer das ist.
Wobei das jetzt Telekom, die Ankündigung ist von Vodafone only bisher, oder?
Nee, nee, beide. Die arbeiten da in diesem Fall zusammen.
Ich spare sich sozusagen die Kosten für Herrn Kram.
Eine ja ja na ja natürlich die müssen ja einen Standardbau also die wollen ja offensichtlich einen Standard bauen und etablieren den sie potentiell weltweit ausrollen. Der deutsche Werbemarkt ist doch uninteressant. Also im Vergleich zu.
Dem weltweiten.
Ja. Also ich meine, ich kann mir schon vorstellen, wie das technisch funktionieren könnte. Sicherlich.
Erklär's mir.
Na ja also ich surfe jetzt Webseite X an. Webseite X guckt sich meine IP-Adresse an.
Aus der IP-Adresse geht hervor, gehört Telekom oder gehört Vodafone. So,
Und damit haben sie dann sozusagen so einen Deal und dann wissen sie, aha okay, dann können wir in diesem Moment jetzt einen Look-up mit dieser IP-Adresse machen
weil wir haben da irgendwie ein Key, wir haben da einen Vertrag wir dürfen bei denen irgendwie abfragen so.
Ja.
Äh äh sagen die halt einfach, ja gib mir mal Profil oder gib mir mal diese ID oder was auch immer sie in dem Moment äh übertragen und äh antworten dann eben erst auf den Riqu fest. Ich meine, das ist die einzige Möglichkeit aus meiner Sicht, wie das überhaupt
technisch ablaufen kann. Und wenn dann halt diese Server äh entsprechend schnell reagieren und äh weltweit verteilt äh ihre Datenbank vorhalten. Ist ja auch jetzt keine Information, die sich am laufenden Meter ändert. Das kann man ja ganz gut cashen. Dann dann
kann das vom Speed her noch funktionieren.
Zwei Probleme. Also.
In der IPV6 Welt, kannst du davon ausgehen, dass die Telefonnummer vielleicht eigene äh eigene IP-Adressen haben in der V4-Welt nicht? Das heißt, ein einfacher Lookup auf Basis der IP-Adresse funktioniert schon mal nicht.
Na ja, weil die auch die V sechs Adressen kommen da ja her. Kennen sie ja auch.
Das ist das eine und das andere ist das ne, aber das sind die Natten halt und great not.
Aber die Ruten auch alles, das heißt, sie sehen ja auch jede IP-Adresse, die von da kommt. Also die können das ja jeder IP-Adresse zuordnen. Egal, ob das V sechs ist oder V4.
Genau damit sind wir bei den zweiten Problemen, der Lockup wird, dann ist er nicht mehr cashbar?
Weil IP-Adresse von Spiegel Online aufgelöst und IP-Adresse von Heise aufgelöst können, gleiche oder unterschiedliche Personen sein und damit wird dieser Request auf jeden Fall dauert äh sehr viel länger.
Weil die erst im Hintergrund sagen müssen, wer ist denn das eigentlich? Ich glaube auch, dass sie genau das machen wollen, also genau das machen wollen, wie du's beschrieben hast. Es wäre für den Seitenaufbau auf jeden Fall äh also ähm.
Wird's wird sehr viel länger dauern, ja. Und Cashper wird es eben nicht sein. Ähm.
Zumal das ja seitenspezifisch ist. Ja also sie sagen ja, sie geben dir ja, wenn du auf der einen Seite bist, den eintocken, wenn du auf der anderen Seite bist, den anderen Token.
Ist schon richtig bei V, also mit V sechs besteht die Möglichkeit und das ist ja auch ein explizites Privacy Feature von IPV6 und einer der Gründe, warum man das haben will, dass man im Prinzip die ganze Zeit äh Adressen durchrotieren kann, ne, also jede App, die sich verbindet, kann im Prinzip schon wieder mit einer anderen IP-Adresse.
Rausgehen, auch wenn es aus demselben Computer rausgeht, ne, von IPV4 hat man das noch so im Kopf, die IP-Adresse hängt am Computer, ja, tut sie auch.
Nur das ist dann eben auch nur diese eine und bei V sechs hat man einfach so einen riesigen Nummernpool. Da kann man irgendwie in die Vollen gehen. Äh das heißt, das müssten Sie in dem Moment dann alles nachführen. Also Sie müssen immer sehen, oh wieder eine neue IP-Adresse.
Müssen dann sozusagen ihr System aktualisieren, damit diese Zuordnung stattfinden kann. Also ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass das äh technisch scheitert so oder so versuchen sie's eben auf diesem Weg und ich weiß nicht, ob das ein,
Ja doch ich weiß, das ist kein guter Weg ist.
Es ist es ist.
Sollen einfach mal damit werben? Hallo, wir sind's, eurer Provider. Wir erzählen gar nix.
Was wäre das für eine geile Werbeaktion? Aber na ja egal. Die wollen halt alle mitverdienen. So ist es halt.
Ich meine, ist ja auch im sonstigen äh Computerbereich. Wer macht das schon noch außer Apple irgendwie? Kenne ich jetzt keinen.
Das Interessante ist ja wirklich, wir haben ja vor kurzem auch noch über diese äh Google-Idee gesprochen, ne, also das Google sagte ja voll geil. Wir
wir mogeln jetzt auch die Cookies ausm Crome raus, aber wir haben vor allen Dingen keinen Super-Cookie, den den wirst du gar nicht mehr los. Also diese Trackerei.
Es ist also einen Punkt gebe ich den, ja.
Wenn das wirklich überall rausgeballert wird, ja, dann wird es am Ende wird der Werbemarkt vollständig Facebook und Google überlassen.
Ist er ohnehin schon zu großen Teilen aber ähm.
Es wäre wahrscheinlich sinnvoll den denen zu überlassen und dann die kaputt zu machen, damit dieser ganze Werbescheiß irgendwann mal aufhört äh und diese Profilbilderei und zielgruppengerichtete Werbung und was nicht alles, aber es ist schon so, dass man,
argumentieren kann, dass ähm die jetzigen Entwicklungen,
kleine Konkurrentinnen von Google und Facebook zerstören, aber die sicherlich nicht,
Ja, also Google sagt im Zweifelsfall einfach, pass auf, wir kontrollieren den Browser-Markt und wir kontrollieren den ähm Endgeräte, mobile Endgerätemarkt, das ist uns völlig egal. Äh was hier ähm,
was was hier irgendwelche Leute wollen, wir bauen unseren eigenen Standard fertig. Und selbst wenn den ähm keiner ähm,
selbst wenn keiner sonst äh unterstützt, äh reicht's für unsere für unsere 70 Prozent Marktanteil, die wir überall haben. Aber es ist nicht gut. Es ist also ich würde,
Deutsche Telekom Vodafone. Ich meine ist, ihr habt jetzt ohnehin nicht den besten Ruf.
Wirklich.
Ja, hauptsächlich, weil's halt scheiß Netz ist in Deutschland, ne, aber ähm.
Provider sage ich nur.
Okay. Ähm wir wollen ein kleines bisschen Update zum Cyber War noch machen. Ähm,
denn das Thema äh bleibt ja eins, ich muss mich hätte jetzt auch demnächst nochmal so einen Konferenzvortrag zu halten. Ähm drei Meldungen, die ich jetzt nur mal so ähm,
die finde ich ein ganz schönes Bild ergeben. Der US-General,
Paul.
Der das Cyber-Command der US-Streitkräfte und die NSA Lande leitet ähm hat bestätigt, dass die USA.
Im Ukrainekrieg offensiv und defensiv und zur Informationsgewinnung Hacking Operationen durchführen. Das ist bemerkenswert, weil hätte er nicht bestätigen müssen und ähm,
offensive Maßnahmen, defensive Maßnahmen und Informationsgewinnung, also Spionage
Sabotage und Schutz vor Angriffen ähm finde ich äh bemerkenswert
Ja, also während man sich überlegt, dass andere sich sehr viel Mühe geben, unbedingt nicht zu sagen, sie werden in irgendwelche krierischen Handlungen äh vermittelt. Äh sagt er, wir haben eine ganze Reihe von Operationen durchgeführt, die das gesamte Spektrum abdecken.
Also quasi, ja? Ähm,
und äh Spezialisten waren bis kurz vor Kriegsbeginn in der Ukraine anwesend, um nach Cyber-Bedrohungen zu jagen,
und dem Land bei der Cyber-Abwehr zu helfen. Unter voller ziviler Kontrolle und gesetzlichem Rahmen. Interessant, also äh.
Faszinierend, dass sie das zugeben, dass sie's tun, in Ordnung. Ähm im defensiven Bereich.
Offensiv haben wir jetzt relativ wenig äh,
gesehen. Gleichzeitig hat die Ukraine ja auch schon vor Jahren schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht mit äh ITC, also mit Cyberangriffen aus äh Russland. Insofern
kann man davon ausgehen, dass die ähm ja vielleicht zumindest der bei der Härtung ihrer Infrastruktur.
Ähm ganz gut. Ähm,
aufgestellt sein können oder du bist vielleicht besser als das äh die Bundesrepublik Deutschland bisher ist. Das fand ich auf jeden Fall bemerkenswert, dann finde ich lustig äh auch das äh absehbar, dass ähm.
Chinas Militär sich äh Gedanken macht, wie das denn mit diesen Styling aussieht,
und ob sie das äh potenziell kaputt machen können, wenn ihnen das nicht mehr gefällt, denn so ein weltumspannendes Satelliten-Internetsystem hat natürlich auch ähm.
Ähm also erstens militärischen Nutzen. Ja, also das kann,
Raketen steuern, kann dafür sorgen, ne, dass irgendwelche äh Militärs äh,
trotz schwerwiegender Angriffe auf Bodeninfrastruktur äh weiter nach Hause kommunizieren können. Damit kannst du vielleicht sogar deine Drohnen steuern. Kannst du auf Rammstein verzichten. Brauchst du nicht mehr die deutschen äh Hilfsmörder,
um deine Drohnen überall rumfliegen zu lassen.
Oder so wie's jetzt grade in der Ukraine gemacht wird. Das also wirklich die komplette ukrainische äh Armee dort mit äh angepasster Software. Alle Einsätze äh koordiniert und das Ganze über Styling macht. Und der Russe hat keine Chance.
Genau, da da hätte China natürlich auch jetzt keinen also das das sieht China natürlich auch, wenn ihnen da die Satelliten durch den Sternenhimmel flattern.
Und machen sich jetzt also darüber Gedanken, äh ob sie potenziell äh also müssen sich überlegen, wie sie denn Starlink potenziell kaputt machen können,
ne finde ich auch also,
Es wäre kein ernstzunehmendes Militär, wenn Sie, wenn Sie sich darüber keine Gedanken machen würden, also jedes Militär der Welt muss sich darüber Gedanken machen, wenn auf einmal ein paar tausend Satelliten äh zur Kommunikation,
um den Planeten segeln, also China überlegt sich das auch und Costa Rica ist im Krieg mit Conti,
Das habe ich jetzt das habe ich ähm.
Reifenfirma.
Nein, der der also mit der auch bald, ja, aber ähm nein, mit der Hackergruppe Conti.
Die äh Conti ist ja russischen Ursprungs, das ist die Hackergruppe, die zu Beginn der Ukrainekrise Entschuldigung, das
Angriff auf die Ukraine ähm also nachdem also die Krise war ja davor quasi, die nach dem Angriff ähm,
sich gespalten hat, weil sie sich nämlich dann pro russisch positioniert hat,
offenbar ukrainische Mitglieder der Gang ja relativ viel geleakt von Conti. Also eine der würde ich sagen größten und berüchtigtsten ähm.
Ja und die haben.
Ähm 7undzwanzig Regierungsinstitutionen inklusive also einiger äh Munisies und äh,
ne, was ist das? Äh Kreis so kleinere Kreis äh wie heißt das denn in Deutschland?
Gemeinden, Gemeinden, ein paar Gemeinden, aber auch auf dem auf der ne auf der Bundesebene haben sie also insgesamt 27 Regierungsinstitutionen gehackt und verlangen 20 Millionen US-Dollar.
Und die äh Regierung Costa Rica sagt, nee, mit euch geben wir euch nicht, ja? Woraufhin die ein Online-Statement veröffentlicht haben, äh wo sie,
die Costa Ricanische Bevölkerung auffordern, auf die Straße zu gehen und zu protestieren, damit die bezahlen. Was auch geil ist, ja.
Krimineller und sagst, so Leute, jetzt geht mal demonstrieren, dass eure Regierung uns 20 Millionen US-Dollar zahlt, damit eure Verwaltung hier wieder funktioniert, also auch echt.
Ja äh alles krass, ja.
Absolut frech.
Es ist ein bisschen unverschämt.
Ja, kann man schon sagen.
Ja. Ähm.
Wo sind die guten Manieren geblieben bei diesen ganzen Erpressern?
Ja bei Conti eh schwer zu finden. Also und jetzt haben die haben die tatsächlich gesagt okay ähm,
Ganz Costa Rica ist in den Händen von Cyberkriminellen und wir erklären jetzt den nationalen Notstand,
weil nämlich der komplette ähm öffentliche Sektor von Costa Rica unter Angriff steht.
Und ähm ja währenddessen hat Conti 6hundert Gigabyte,
Regierungsdaten veröffentlicht mit der Drohung mehr zu äh mehr bereitzustellen, ja?
Also das ist echt faszinierend. Eigentlich eine Eskalation, die solche Ransomer Gruppen.
Nichts also versuchen zu vermeiden, ja also klar den Landkreis Anhalt Bitterfeld haben sie platt gekloppt ich glaube das war was war das denn?
Zwar nicht Conti, sondern ah, wie hieß denn ihr denn? Oh nicht, sondern irgendwie so eine.
Fällt der Name gerade nicht ein, irgendwas mit irgendwas mit ähm mir fällt's gerade nicht ein. Ähm aber ja äh interessant, dass sie offenbar Costa Rica für so.
Also auch für so einerseits so lukrativ halten, dass sie's auch mit diesem Staat eskalieren wollen, ja? Dass sie sagen,
Leute, geht auf die Straße, protestiert für uns, damit wir die 20 Millionen kriegen, damit wir endlich äh eure,
Eure Verwaltung hier wieder hochfahren können. Also das ist äh eine faszinierende äh Entwicklung, wenn ich ehrlich sein soll.
Hätte ich so nicht mit gerechnet. Also wenn jemand gesagt hätte, glaubst du, eine Gruppe wird jemals eine.
Eine einen Staat erpressen und dabei sich an die Bürgerinnen und Bürger wenden und der Staat sagt dann, wir sind im Krieg mit denen ähm hätte ich jetzt nicht, hätte ich jetzt erstmal nicht innerhalb dieses Jahres gesehen.
Mögest du in interessanten Zeiten leben. Chinesischer Fluch. Ja ja.
So, dann kommen wir noch zu ein paar kurz äh Kurzmeldungen eigentlich nur.
Grüne und FDP fordern ja seit längerem dass das,
BSI unabhängiger werden soll, also vor allem aus dem äh aus der Ägide des BMI, also das Innenministeriums und damit auch,
von den Geheimdiensten gelöst wird, damit es unabhängig nur auf Sicherheit zuarbeiten kann wurde die Bundesregierung aufgefordert bis zum Ende des Jahres ein Konzept vorzulegen.
Wie das unabhängig und,
Werden kann und zur Zentralstelle für IT-Sicherheit ausgebaut werden soll. Das ist etwas, was der Chaos-Computerclub auch schon lange fordert, das fordere ich eigentlich immer, wenn ich irgendeine
Stellungnahme zur IT-Sicherheitsgesetz und schreibe. Ähm ich glaube, das erste Mal habe ich das zwanzig.
Das hört sich 14 oder so aufgeschrieben, weiß ich gar nicht wann genau ähm und wahrscheinlich haben äh hat's jetzt CCC schon sehr viel früher gefordert. Das klingt erstmal gut, bis Ende des Jahres werden wir dafür also hoffentlich einen Entwurf haben.
Beschluss des Haushaltsausschusses ne des Bundestages.
Die Bundesregierung muss jetzt ein Konzept schreiben bis Ende des Jahres. Ja ähm.
Dann hat, auch das ist schon etwas länger her, aber soll noch mal erwähnt werden, der Bundesgerichtshof hat bestätigt, dass die Veröffentlichung des Glyphosatgutachtens durch frag den Staat 2018 in Ordnung war,
ja? Ähm das war diese Kampagne Zensurheberrecht. Ähm wo.
Arne hat uns das hier sehr ausführlich erzählt, ja. Das Urteil des Oberlandesgericht,
war ja im letzten Jahr schon, wo gesagt wurde, sie durften dieses
Gutachten zu den Krebsrisiken beim Einsatz von Glyphosat veröffentlichen, als jetzt 20018 getan haben. Ähm aber das wurde jetzt nochmal durch,
urteilt bis zum,
Bundesgerichtshof und der hat da jetzt auch nochmal Recht gegeben. Die Forderung von frag den Staat bleibt. Wir brauchen jetzt eine gesetzliche Klarstellung, dass sie Veröffentlichung behördlicher Dokumente Urheberrechtlich immer zulässig ist.
Dazu muss Paragraph fünf des Urheberrechtsgesetzes geändert werden, einen Vorschlag dazu haben wir bereits 20019 formuliert,
Also Sie sagen ja, ne, das ist nicht,
in also selbstverständlich ist das im im Interesse der Öffentlichkeiten, das wurde ja auch von niemandem bemängelt, sondern es wurde gesagt, nee, dieses Gutachten, das hat er bei unser Urheberrecht und deswegen dürfen wir's nicht.
Geben. Hälten Sie jetzt vor dem BGH verloren, hätten Sie ungefähr 25.000 Euro bezahlen müssen. Sie haben aber äh relativ viele Spenden bekommen und äh,
sieht. Sieht also gut aus. Also das Ding sie haben jetzt ein BGH-Urteil, was schon echt
echt stark ist, ja. Das äh Urteil ist vom Januar eingegangen ist im Februar, veröffentlicht haben sie's äh Ende März bis hin bisschen verspätet äh wollte ich das hier noch ähm,
wiedergeben,
Und dann gibt's eine relativ interessante,
Meldung, mit der ich jetzt nicht gerechnet hätte, äh bei Golem. Äh.
Und zwar haben wir darüber gesprochen, dass Cell Broadcast für Warnmeldungen.
Als äh System verpflichtend werden soll in ähm,
Deutschland, ja und das ist auch so, soll im September 22 Zoll eine neue die Waren SMS,
getestet werden und die Wirtschaftswoche berichtet jetzt, was mich ernsthaft wundert, dass nicht genug Geräte ähm,
dieses Sale-Broadcast unterstützen würden. Und das kann ich mir ehrlich gesagt gar nicht vorstellen, weil das Teil des Standards ist.
Also.
Also das GSM-Standards.
Ja und ich kann mir ehrlich, also ich.
Die meisten Handys, die derzeit im Gebrauch sind, müssten die Hersteller äh bei den meisten Handys, die derzeit im Gebrauch sind,
müssten Hersteller, die für den Empfang von Warn-SMS erforderlichen Einstellungen per Update nachrüsten.
Weil es so eine Vielfalt an Geräten gibt ähm.
Geht man davon aus, dass man so ungefähr mittelfristig 60 Prozent der äh Geräte schafft und,
sagt, dass es erst mit oder von Apple sagen sie, dass er das mit iOS 16 ähm,
im Herbst kommen wird und das kann ich mir ehrlich gesagt irgendwie nicht vorstellen.
Also ich habe jetzt auch äh mich hat das auch äh extrem überrascht. Ich habe auch mal geschaut, es gibt durchaus Support ähm,
Dokumente von Apple zu Notfallwarnungen und offiziellen Warnmeldungen auf dem äh iPhone.
Die man angeblich aktivieren kann und deaktivieren kann, wobei ich finde jetzt hier irgendwie diese genannte Stille gar nicht, wo man das äh aktivieren kann, deaktivieren kann,
von daher ist mir das selber auch gerade etwas unklar. Warte mal, hier Mitteilung.
Ja, weiß ich jetzt auch gerade nicht. Also dem müssen wir nochmal nachgehen. Das ist mir ein bisschen,
Auch ich bin bisher davon ausgegangen, dass das alles in äh mit dem Standard abgedeckt ist und von daher auch implementiert ist und das war früher ja auch in allen Telefonen definitiv der Fall.
Ja, also ich bin da irgendwie nicht.
Nicht so wirklich von überzeugt, ja? Was, was, was hier berichtet wird, aber immerhin, selbst wenn, dann ähm also ein Update, was Standardkonformität herstellt, kann eigentlich nicht allzu lange auf sich warten lassen. Insofern dürfte es.
Keine so große Verzögerung nach sich bringen.
Also es könnte, so wie ich das so sehe, also es,
iPhone ist diese Funktionalität drin. Es kann natürlich sein, dass es irgendwie in Deutschland abgeschaltet ist.
Das das würde schon eher äh da das könnte ich mir schon eher vorstellen. Das ist wahrscheinlich irgendwann vor acht Jahren irgendein Vollpfosten in Verhandlungen mit Apple gesagt hat, schaltet das aus, das haben wir nicht.
Das das kann ich mir schon eher vorstellen, aber äh dass das dass,
etablierter Standard, der in anderen Ländern ja auch funktioniert, in den Geräten irgendwie nicht verfügbar ist, kann ich mir irgendwie nicht vorstellen.
Ja, also hier habe ich zum Beispiel eine Information, die ist schon ein bisschen älter, also CB Alert, activated by Deephoite und iPhone Sold in Grease
Ist jetzt eine Information, die sich jetzt gerade nur auf Griechenland bezieht, aber diese Fußalität existiert und ist halt in einigen Ländern auch vorinstalliert. Hier steht auch CB Alert und also auch wenn man das irgendwie kann.
Dieses Setting existiert bei mir jetzt hier in Deutschland auf meinem aktuellen iPhone so nicht,
Sehe ich hier nicht an der Stelle, wo es angeblich sein soll. Ähm von daher,
unklar, ist aber etwas, was sie äh mühelos bis zum Sofa-Update wieder,
Einschalten können. Von daher glaube ich, ist die Panik,
es jetzt alles sinnlos ist, äh etwas übertrieben. Wie es bei Android aussieht, dazu kann ich überhaupt nichts sagen.
Ich auch nicht. So, damit sind wir am Ende der Sendung.
So sieht's aus. Genau.
Interessante Mischung an an Dingen, die so passieren. Sage ich mal.
Positives, negatives. China will mein Starling wieder kaputt machen, jetzt wo ich eine Schüssel habe.
Frechheit. Gelbe Ge.
Deine Schüsse lassen die heile, keine Sorge. Die werfen wahrscheinlich eher. Die waren sich eher Gedanken, wer ihnen Satelliten sie da irgendwie in welche Richtung stupsen müssen. Dass das ganze Starling irgendwie äh verglüht.
Also es gibt ja da durchaus Hitzköpfe, ne? Die sind ja auch mal vor ein paar Jahren auf die Idee gekommen. Man müsste ja mal so testweise einen Satelliten abschießen, also so so völlig beknackte Idee, gutes,
glaube, das werden sie jetzt auch nicht mehr machen, weil das verhagelt ihnen natürlich ihre Raumfahrt auch, aber äh es zeigt sie halt immer wieder, dass
dass da so wenn so die Strukturen auseinanderlaufen und wenn irgendwie solche Städte ähm wenn solche.
Staaten verrohen, dann,
können auch ganz furchtbare äh Sachen passieren, sehen wir ja gerade.
Na ja, also ich.
Also es überrascht mich jetzt nicht. Ja und das hat auch nichts mit Verrohen zu tun. Wenn China so ein Netzwerk bauen würde, wäre die Amnesty Ersten, die sich darüber Gedanken machen würden, wie sie das kaputt.
Aber jetzt nicht unbedingt mit physisch zerschießen so, was bei Starling, glaube ich, auch.
Davon war auch nicht die Rede.
Ja, ich sage ja nur, dass soweit waren die auch schon mal, ne? Aber das ganze äh softwaretechnisch oder strahlungstechnisch in Griff zu kriegen. Ich glaube, das wird auch schwierig.
Also äh Starlink äh hat zumindest derzeit eine Resilienz, die einen doch eine ordentliche Denkabbe gibt.
Ja und äh das Darling, die das hat äh denke ich äh also das Darling mit dem Militär zu tun hat, ist ziemlich klar.
Ja, also dass du so etwas nicht bauen wirst, ähm weltweit, ohne dass das US-Militär äh das erstens, sagen wir mal, äh genehmigt.
Und im Zweifelsfall sogar davon hier profitiert. Äh es ist, glaube ich, allen klar.
Und äh natürlich muss sich
muss sich jedes Land der Erde was potenziell sage ich mal sich nicht sicher sein kann, dass es nicht irgendwann mal mit den USA Stress hat äh sich auch darüber Gedanken machen.
Äh was was das bedeutet, wenn die da jetzt auf einmal übern über ein Satellitennetzwerk verfügen? Weltweit.
Also ich wäre enttäuscht äh von von einer äh Regierung oder Armee, die sich diese Gedanken nicht macht. Oder?
Da ist sicherlich recht und ist schön, dass du jetzt nicht enttäuscht bist von den Chinesen.
Das wird die Chinesen sicherlich äh freuen, dass sie äh dass sie meine Erwartungen, dass sie meinen Erwartungen gerecht werden, ja meinen moderaten,
moderaten Erwartungen, äh die ich jetzt von so einer ähm aufstrebenden Welt macht. Äh,
durchaus finde, kann ich das schon verlangen.
Gut, wir hoffen natürlich, dass ihr äh dass eure moderaten Erwartungen an unsere Sendung,
sozusagen auch erfüllt wurden, ne? Für dem gerecht werden äh konnten und entlassen euch jetzt erst mal in die Woche und dann äh hören wir uns ein paar Tagen wieder.
Oder so.
Ja oder wir sehen uns auf der Fusion.
Ja, alles noch ein bisschen hin. Also, bis dann. Tschüss.
Bis denn, tschau tschau.